[Music]
[Music]
everybody it's gary vaynerchuck good to
see everybody happy to be here and just
ready to rock and roll so let's let's
rock and roll
let's get right into it how's it going
Gary let's go bro how are you I'm good
right I watched your live stream on
tik-tok for the almond challenge I was
amazing thank you so much it was so
great to see everybody come together so
cool what's cooking with you my man
now much just continuing to you know
Brian tick tock cuz that's where the
attention is but also trying to get
people over to YouTube and Instagram
it's been going pretty well so just
trying to you know spread across all the
platforms I love that ok what can I help
you
yeah so I have a question for you so how
would a creator balance ambition with
while also not over judging themselves I
think it's just having a real
conversation with yourself you know just
really just going there you know like
even though you know even the way you
asked that question obviously you've
been listening enough of like either my
themes or other themes or you got there
yourself like the reality is is that you
know ambition and patience seem to be
opposites but when blended together
really lead to a higher level of
happiness and so I couldn't I couldn't
push harder for people to figure out how
to get there I think a lot of times when
you know people think they might be
complacent or not pushing hard enough
when they just need a rest
you know and that's ok too and so I
actually you know I find it I find it
easier now you know I think it came
natural to me after years of practice
but I think the fact that that's even on
your radar is already a winning formula
you know the fact that you're even
debating that already puts you in a good
spot
yeah I mean I enjoyed the process so I I
love the hustle I love working from the
time I wake up to the time I go to bed I
enjoy it yeah I just trying to figure
out that balance mentally not even so
much and what I'm doing but more just
you know up here in the head yeah but
yeah and then any advice for starting a
business with a family member because I
know you've done stuff with AJ and and
you're getting on that one you just got
to make sure that you value the person
more than the money and the clout or
respect you know it's a really
challenging game family businesses but
the reality is is if you can just love
somebody more than you love the money or
the clout or the credit then you'll be
in a good spot for me it was more credit
it was more like hey Dad hey AJ I'm a
better businessman than you and and that
creates friction for for them I think
they value two dollars a little bit more
I don't judge that I just think they do
more than me so that worked out a little
bit in the fact that that's how that
broke down with us but I think you've
got to figure out if the person you're
going into business with has the same
ambitions as you do is it money is it is
it you know the credit of who did it you
know I think communication is just
everything in life and definitely in
family businesses cool thank you I
appreciate that
some rapid-fire questions I am awesome
we're doing this yes so this is our
little new segment called small talk
plate after tik-tok obviously and Evans
and I ask you just like a rapid-fire of
questions okay specifically for like I
guess our tick-tock audience everybody's
watching right now we're always trying
to hack and you know this is a very meta
moment I talked a lot about put yourself
in a position to create content so Evan
the car guy here is crushing on tick
tock so you know we've been we've been
bringing friends that we've interact
with Europe you know 90 percent kind of
fans 10 percent kind of people we know
and we layered on this concept because
we're gonna chop it and put it onto tick
tock so hopefully this will be
entertaining and more importantly you
know we'll see how
we figure out and use it and tick-tock
so let's try it out okay first question
what in your opinion makes a good
content creator like in just a few words
lack of the arm lack of fear I like that
great okay who is the creator that
impresses you and why uh Zach king
just cuz that [ __ ] is crazy like my
brain doesn't work that way just so
creative you know I like quick fired
volume his masterpieces
so that's who stands out for me that's
great and then last quick question
biggest mistake a creator can make
making the decision on the piece of
content for the audience before they put
it out aka you know nice little graphic
there's um you know but that's it
yeah that's times up I gotta play by the
rules so thank you so much problem thank
you I think they want to ask you a
couple pricing on some cards because
you're the hannam of sports cards okay
look I have a few Carter I'm gonna ask
you to guess the price and then and it
will be good that's the current price
yes guess the price of the car so here's
a let's see 2008 Serena Williams guess
the price of that card eight bucks 813
Wow okay can go okay hold on
second one second one let's see
Cristiano Ronaldo right here ah 27 11 11
all right hey hey the first one was like
spot-on I got two more know I was crazy
that was crazy that was right on the
money okay
Michael Jordan Bulls right here alright
but that's not a good this is a reprint
so this isn't like and like a shitty
grainy uh 60 bucks
25 25 right alright okay one more one
more
let's see we got some jets for you Sam
Donald right here 2008 party are these
your cards I bought these for this
I love it listen I'm here because I
totally respect and I and I been
utilizing your strategies from the 64
pieces of content and I actually blew up
my business and I wanted to come on and
say thank you so much but I want to give
you a little context of what I'm talking
about two and a half years ago I was
looking at a wall in rehab and I didn't
know how I got there you know 16 years
my marriage was failing and to
complicate things even more my wife came
down or was diagnosed with stage 4
stomach cancer so my drinking escalated
as you can imagine and I got two young
kids they were 10 years old at the time
and I knew I had to change so I went to
rehab
I got silvered up and I came out man and
I was so humbled on my parents help me
get a 25-foot RV I'm living in this RV
and I don't know what the hell I'm gonna
do with myself you know I'm silver but
I'm just completely like what am I gonna
do I found this product that I
absolutely loved and I and I I started
watching motivational videos on YouTube
and Gary beat your all over social media
absolutely so man I bought your book
crushing it and I'm like dude
this guy's got exactly what I need right
so I'm I'm utilizing the strategies I'm
loving everything and then you come out
with the 64 pieces of content I start
blasting out all my stuff all over
tick-tock Instagram you know they deal
and I absolutely crushed it so my
question to you Gary is my story my
struggle Len is too much I don't want to
just keep saying my story over and over
but I know that I want to help people
right so another thing is you know I'm
in this army
I'm laying in the top bunk and I come up
with this this thing of positivity so
the positivity gangster I create this
shirt right I want to help people I want
to help people with positivity I listen
to you every day man you're you're like
a legend you're alleging too many of us
I want to give back by selling this
shirt the positivity gangster t-shirt I
want to donate all the profits to help
feed the hungry what you did with the
all in challenge what you did with the
tick-tock marathon I watched it from
bell the Bell you're making an impact
you're doing amazing things and I just
that's what I want to know what can I do
dad value to you Gary rather you can
bring value to me if you just make
yourself happy the end like ah you know
do good things make yourself happy I'm
good I don't need anything from you I
need you to you know you getting value
for my free content and that bringing
you happiness which then allows you to
bring somebody else happiness is
disproportionately the best gift you can
give me I don't need [ __ ]
well utilizing your 64 pieces of content
you changed my life Gary you showed me
what to do I took action I grew that
business to over a million dollars in a
year and it's it's just keep going and
going and going and I just I have so
much gratitude for you man
makes me happy I gotta choose me I like
him I love you back man he pushed her
thank you just but no I mean the world
to me if the vfan would come together
and help me feed the hungry with the
positivity gangster t-shirts you can go
to my website I'm donating all the
profits and thank you so much for having
me take care of yourself stay well but
let's keep barakatuh rolling so I'm just
relaxing hi Alex
how are you dying right now how are you
how are you oh my god your team is
amazing thank you what's cooking I've
only just been waiting six years for you
Gary it's okay thank you so much well
we're here let's do it
you know I know you always like to know
how people find you so I thought I would
show you this is how I found you six
years ago and just before I go into my
question I just need to tell you um four
years ago when I left my last agency job
I was at T we WI and I started house of
social I crossed the street where I live
here and I wrote you the longest email
and I just cried so much because I just
knew that if I was to put into practice
everything that you teach and you pass
on that I was gonna be okay my mom is my
hero but you came right after and you've
been I just want you to know you've been
with me for these past four years and
trust me I know that four years is like
baby it's like I'm only just scratching
these little surface that I'm on I'm so
excited for what's to come but I just
want you to know you have been with yes
if I had to wait come on I'm here now to
talk to you the universe knows what's
happening I love it thank you so much
Alex okay so my question to you is I
know how amazing you are at having the
capability of looking at a product and a
service and find innovative ways of how
to package it or sell it so that's where
I'm coming from with an angle of my
question to you so what do I do I do the
mix of consultancy and education those
are the two things of houses virtual
consultancy my consultancy packs from
either like hourly packs to make it real
simple because here in Dubai things are
not as you know mature of me Europe or
the u.s. so I got my consultancy okay
and then I've got my education so since
four years I will do master classes
short courses boot camps what else by
doing yeah my so glad this mood
I do a lot of free stuff so my last
master class in January now now my
master classes are free so it will be
like two hundred plus people that will
come I do quarterly free meetups and of
course there's like a ton of free
content out there so you you know giving
for me it's the thing that comes more
natural so I knew that I had to give
give give give get also because here in
this region it's still kind of a new
concept so now to even give you more of
a timely context since we got into
quarantine which for us here in Dubai
was since March and so I think it was
earlier than you guys I knew right away
that I had to go into your lives that I
had to do live content so I've been
doing this no old meanie class with Alex
and I started back from March 5th so I
think we're going into our 50th episode
real soon
three times a week now I've scaled it to
twice a week because here things are
almost at 90 percent normal okay so I'm
still continuing
but Gary I don't know what happened
something and it took me a while to
understand what was happening
my mum clocked it much earlier than me
something crazy magical special happen
with these live sessions I was just
coming in showing up I danced I'm loud
I'm you know I'm just like everybody's
everybody's at their best when them
their themselves
yeah but because I was just myself I
didn't really understand what was
happening because they would you were
you were in the zone I was assisting
myself and and I was just being me that
I have been for the past four years when
you maybe come to my master classes in
my boot camps but I don't know maybe I
was just a little bit more extra because
now I'm stuck at home and now we've got
all this time and I just want to be with
my people like I just want to be with my
community because now I cannot run my
events like I can't be with them and
something really beautiful and magical
happen in these in this kind of like
month-and-a-half where the dims and the
emails and the feedback was like this is
like your energy your energy and the
sinta and at the same time I'm teaching
like Facebook Ads or email marketing how
do storytelling in like all these like
topics and so something really magic
will happen it and I was never asking
for a cell I was never going in hey you
know do my like nothing I was doing that
through Facebook Ads and my email mark I
got you
sorry and the magical thing that
happened was so my mom is my financial
manager she was on that said to me what
takes you a month what takes you two
months to do in revenue you've done it
in a month so that was like mind-blowing
to me where I wasn't even asking for
anything in those lives and I'm moving
value
it's Jab Jab Jab right literally the way
this started pull up the book yeah it
was that Jeff it was that Alex you were
you that book is a micro of giving and
then asking that's the micro that was a
book I wrote six years ago on how to do
that in in content Oh what you're what
you're what you're radiating right now
is you were living that in the macro
it's how I live my macro like I I'm so
focused on this community that's
watching this right now
period right the end and I thought that
the most mind-blowing thing for me was
like wow I thought I was giving before
because I would do a master class that I
used to charge and then as soon as I got
a good deal with a venue I didn't I
starts charging and I was doing a master
class that too many people would come
and it was free so I thought I was
giving about like you were ever giving
with expectation of a conversion
probably yes yeah where you were you
were subconsciously you know you were
you were giving it was it was giving
with the expectation of a conversion or
the up or the deep short-term hope of a
conversion versus giving in perpetuity
and knowing good things will happen yeah
and that's what happened in part to aha
right so to get
to the actual question which is well
it's two questions and then one ask I
launched an online Academy last year
because I knew I had to take my stuff
online its online courses that are as
interactive as I can and then there's
biweekly mentorship sessions here in
this part of the world online learning
is still not as mature as maybe Europe
or the u.s. so I knew I was going to
have a difficult time with the
conversion my two questions to you are
when I see the huge volume of people
that are coming and getting it for free
and when I look at the price and by the
way my question is not necessarily okay
Gary I want more people to buy it's more
about I think I am missing something on
how I am packaging my online academy
business because what I've learned is
what people want the most it's access to
me on a 101 because only ponies access
it's always a choice oh and you know
even when you do group mentorship
sessions it's kind of okay but then it's
when you get one-on-one that you really
get real deep with a person solely
looking because people are getting value
for their money information just
information you're competing against
unlimited stuff that's free on the
internet a Utah I know well that's life
that's the border so my question to you
is when I look at how I've set up my
Academy which is there's three tiers of
membership like you can do three months
six or twelve you get access to my
online content and you get bi-weekly
mentorships when people say we really
really really want to see access to you
raise the price on the access to you is
there something that I need to do on how
to really raise the cost of access to
you but if they're not if there's not
much of a higher volume in converting ah
okay I get you so they'll get more
one-on-ones with me so I have to put in
their one-on-ones with Alex more and
charge more and charge me more and feel
that more access to the online Academy
like to look everybody can do it how
they want to do it my favorite thing is
put out all the concept for free and
then the access to you becomes ten
thousand dollars an hour eventually
other
well other people want to do conversion
where they film once and they charged
$99 a month like you know everyone gets
to do it the way they want to do it
my my my my favorite point of view is
kind of you know content is so
commoditized on the internet there's so
much I mean all my content is free oh
yeah I sometimes give away my courses
this is what's crazy
I wouldn't I get some but the biggest
part of that sentence was sometimes yeah
yeah
yeah so just give it all the way just
give it all the way their funnels you
give it away with the hope that it gets
them hooked and then they pay you versus
just building so much value that then a
small group sees the value and doing
one-on-one with you and you charge a
premium for that they're getting value
and everybody else's you're building a
bigger opportunity grass but that's
that's how I like it and I don't get to
be right I just get to be me gotcha so
they'll okay okay I totally get you I I
see now my mom would kill me if I don't
ask this question everybody wants Alex's
energy how do I sell my energy I do by
doing 101 consulting at a higher price
okay but if people are not kind if
there's not a lot of volume of people
converting for an online economy where
the price is I feel so low I'm guessing
because it's because that's a it's
because the products not valuable
because they're different information
for free exactly and because they're not
really doing getting what they really
want which is got it I get you okay
last question listen let me do a write
book well I know you're going to you
you're built on doing short-term
conversions
really yes you just like that's what we
just spent the whole time talking about
okay would you consider being a guest on
my meanie class with Alex
IG live show would you consider it not
until you show me that you've become a
marathon runner versus a sprinter for
over a year and what what what do I need
to do cracking practically practicality
what do I need to show you that put out
content for free and starts stop selling
low-cost things and then start selling
$2,000 an hour or $5,000 make up the
math in access to you and do that for a
year and show me and then I'll consider
it so I have to raise my prices higher
for my 101 and then everything else free
I got that I can do that thank you son
mine thank you sure that would brought
some value to people face hard hey Howie
nice to meet you I mean I'm I'm good I
hope you're good too I am thank you
where are you from I'm from India I'm
from Delhi in India so great so first of
all thank you for all the motivation and
all the content that you you have out
there and thank you to Zen and to Dustin
for helping me out on the back side
thank you so much so my question mainly
was what is your advice for a college
student who wants to get a better time
management and upgrade their skill sets
be it like a workshop or an online
course because I mean how are you how do
you learn right now I'm in college so
that doesn't know how how do you learn
how do you learn well reading listening
being class like how do you learn well a
mixture of will generally I mean that's
you know the answer is two things one
you have to figure out how you learn to
you need to figure out you know that
experience is much more interesting than
being a student so you want to you know
a why you know and then and then see we
need to audit the judgment and what I
mean by that is
why do you think you're not good at time
management why do you want to get better
at it why are you judging yourself on
that I mean because at the end of the
day maybe you know I'll just spend half
of the day relaxing not doing much stuff
scrolling through Instagram or YouTube
you know then if it's a small activity
it it will persist for maybe a day or a
week rather than what I can finish in a
few hours we'll have you considered the
fact that you may not want to be doing
those things a little bit but you have
to get through college you have to
complete certain things I understand but
I don't think you're gonna get better at
it I don't think you like it yeah
everybody procrastinate [ __ ] they don't
like and everybody does things that they
love I've got a million things I'm
supposed to be doing I'm procrastinating
them because I don't like them but I'm
up to two o'clock in the morning last
night looking up sports cars cuz I like
it but then I mean how would you find
something that you know energizes you
because right now I'm just 19 so I know
I have a long way which is amazing I you
know for me I tend to like to ask people
to really slow everything down and try
to figure out what like really audit the
last 19 years of your life and try to
figure out what what you like yeah yeah
and
another question for you like I'm I have
this interest in me okay I have this
interest in you know digital media and
that's why I am doing a media course
right now in college so I want to know
how can you find a scale or a job that
you know you can enhance throughout your
college life so that when you are out
there in the job field you are able to
learn more rather than going from you
know the bottom of the pyramid learning
that skill from the bottom skills are a
commodity and actually not so valuable I
think what you shall focus on is
interacting with people all right I
think if you're spending time in college
what I would challenge yourself to do is
to meet as many people as possible and
really get much better on your people
skills and empathy and compassion and
listening and friendships because the
skills are college is not gonna teach
you the skills of real life yeah true I
know it's true like there listen many
have to go through college and get a
degree to go into the field that they
like but you don't learn about you know
you know no matter how much somebody
trains for war once the war starts it's
different no matter how many videos you
watch on YouTube about playing
basketball when you get on the court and
somebody elbows you in the chest
you're not playing basketball it's like
yeah like school is not built for what
you're asking for but what you could do
though on the lip side is use this time
to really start to learn people you know
because you know teaching teaching can
be done in a lot of different ways you
know and and consuming information and
gathering information is is great but
the reality is you can do that outside
of the school system outside of
university you know yeah life is so much
about actually doing of course you can
learn certain skills top doctors lawyers
a lot like you have to memorize those
things you have to learn those like but
like but like doing if you're talking
about business yeah I mean reading about
running Instagram ads is different than
running them right you know reading you
know thinking about how
make a podcast versus actually making a
podcast like you know you know I just
getting into that I think learning more
throw the price work I get worried that
people think like I hate college or just
a mad
I hate debt you know I hate that people
think it's a ticket to a skill or
happiness yeah you know there's a lot of
great things about college people mature
it's a time you know it's an age group
you know 18 to 20 to 17 to 23
you're a very different person and
you're gonna take a course on project
management or on you know advertising I
mean you know they're teaching in
college for advertising is antiquated
yeah you have to do okay all right thank
you so much hi Kelly who's this little
one yeah he's Lucas he's the reason I've
been watching you
I love it Helu 'kiss and he's teething I
apologize now and we're all teething in
one way or another yes you can go ahead
go where we're based in southern Spain
and a place called mark Bayer I don't
know if you've heard of it and I grew up
in the wine business so yeah yeah and my
mum has a property management business
she's had it she's been in the property
management business for 10 years but
she's only had her business for the last
three so it's quite new and it's kind of
like a two-pronged business so it's she
went she looked after properties of
people that owned them but don't live
here and then those people also like for
her to rent them out for holiday season
and and I've been helping her sits up in
our maternity there's one thing that you
said about being online in 2020 that if
you're not if you're a business that's
not online then you're basically dead in
the water and I just thought I've got to
help my mum I've really got a you know
pusher on that side because that's not a
her strength and to be honest it's not
massively mine either but
I can learn and I can help especially
now I've got well a bit of time I've got
two children under two but so my
question is we want to expand the
company we have about twenty four
properties at the moment we want to get
more properties but how can we do that
when everyone is after they're the same
the same thing and we don't really know
where they are you know there's hundreds
here we don't know who they are and when
you say those 100 here's sorry little
guy like Lucas wouldn't you say when
they're after the same thing I just want
to make sure I fully understood you I
mean when every other property
management company is after the same
client they all want you know you've got
a little better
yeah but how how do we promote ourselves
because because the way I was thinking
is Facebook ads but that is one we need
to employ people to do that for us
because I have had a go before lockdown
and and it amounts to nothing but I mean
I know I haven't put any effort into it
really well good news anything you don't
put any effort into always announced
another yeah I know I mean it's a lot to
learn isn't it but it is that's why it's
good and that's why it works you know
what else takes a lot of effort push ups
and if you do it every day
you'll get muscles yeah well I mean what
I was think what the Facebook ads is
because it's not particularly my forte
either maybe it's better to pay somebody
else to do that for us the only problem
is if you don't if you don't know it if
you don't know how to judge out then you
might waste money that way too and I
kind of like the idea of you learning
you're so young you learning that skill
is something that I'm not yeah Kelly
you're that young I'm a little bit
younger than you I'm 40 tell your young
is [ __ ] you're not [ __ ] Lucas young
but 40 like you're gonna minimum we live
another 40 years like you're young and
learning this skill right now
is very important sorry Lucas Luke
listen okay Lucas Lucas listen to me
you're gonna clip you're gonna clip this
video one day and you're gonna use it on
your social media for you brother likes
baby you know I think I think that I
think you should learn it I like the way
you ask the question I like your energy
around it I think you should learn it
because it's putting in those 15 to 20
hours is something that's gonna pay
dividends for you forever Facebook will
be paper thing is the only way it's an
extremely good way to go right now
Spain's prices on a super super low and
I think you should absolutely it's an
incredible good use of your time you
learning it even if it fails for your
business cuz you didn't figure out the
creatives yes you know it's still going
to be the best thing you do not going to
learn [ __ ] printing a flyer and putting
in people's mailboxes but you'll learn
an obnoxious amount if you put 20 hours
in to run learning how to run Facebook
ads you literally go to Google and you
go how do I run Facebook Ads yeah I mean
I think I have started it and I did run
a few but yeah I mean remember Kelly
it's the ad it's the picture of the
video that's going you can put a picture
out there there's nothing new picture or
video that gets you 10 leads so it's not
a skill of knowing how to do it that's
the commodity anybody can learn how to
ride a bike or dribble a basketball
it's about being a BMX superstar it's
about being Isiah Thomas you get it have
to be good at it so takes reps because
we've also started Instagram as well
again that was something that we didn't
have do you think basic yet okay this
thing that's the only thing we should be
on Facebook I think it's
I think it's a bird I think your
property conversion Facebook just is
crushes but Instagram building up your
personalities also can work okay well
what do you think
good luck when you follow us on
Instagram Gary weekend which they care
oh I some holiday rentals and there it
is got it just to make sure I do it out
the roads Dustin also just I'm an
emergency so I'm gonna throw up up in
nine minutes
Thank You Kelly hi how are you every
single morning
I'm from Biloxi Mississippi it's a
little town about an hour outside New
Orleans yeah I'm just gonna give you a
quick backstory I know you have to hurry
up
I am from Mississippi and you always
joke about moving back to Mississippi
which I did during the quarantine I
moved out to Los Angeles about to over
two years ago when I lived in
Mississippi I was working for a
corporate company and I loved working
there I was in the marketing department
but I just wanted something more I
wanted to work for myself
so I went the entrepreneur route and
joined my oldest brother I have four
brothers out in Los Angeles to open a
company so I kind of dropped everything
and moved out there on whim and loved
living there but it was hard working
with family very hard which I then they
would be that hard so we he and I are
very different workers
he's very money motivated which is great
but I'm more family oriented which he is
too but I feel like my family and people
who were close to me their relationships
are way more important than any amount
of money and I think that working with
him really showed how much of we were
like different in that way
so now I
I'm back you feel that she was unfair to
you and chose money over your
relationship as a brother and sister yes
sometimes yeah do you think do you think
and I mean this in a good way
do you think it's possible that he was
treating you professionally and that you
were looking for some level of nepotism
or like a little bit more compassion
even though you got you two were putting
on the jerseys of doing business or do
you think he was like do you not like
his morals and the way he thought about
things I would say with more morals we
don't even need to go deeper than that I
just wanted to make sure that you
weren't caught in youthful entitlement
because then that's your vulnerability
and I just wanted to double click on
that you've given me what I needed let's
keep moving back you're back in
Mississippi yes I'm 28 years old
so try I've tried a few different things
I'm still working for him full time I
moved here because I'm actually moving
to Boston in August so my boyfriend
lives in Boston I've actually never been
to Boston but I'm moving there and I'm
in this situation now where I'm trying
to decide do I stay on this route of
working with for my brother I'm still
working for him
or going back into the corporate world
so I'm almost at an opposite I'm what
about a lovely mouth what about what
about the obvious third one which you
just answered you don't like corporate
you don't like working for your brother
why don't you try to figure something
out that isn't going back to something
you already know you don't like yes and
that's what I'm trying to do what about
I put them out what an elephant thing
what about doing a lot of homework five
hours a day on your favorite 25 to 50
small businesses and entrepreneurs in
the Boston area and reaching out to them
and maybe working for someone that you
admire build yourself up save some money
and go from there yeah and and that's
where I hit a few road boxes is the
money situation of course just like
everybody else working for my
I had no benefits I you know I didn't
have any type of savings to fall back on
so I had you think I'm up when I was in
LA and I can your boyfriend I'm sorry to
interrupt but boyfriend hold it down for
a little bit does it give you some
breathing room well see I don't like to
I don't want to say handouts but I don't
like no wait I respect the [ __ ] out of
that
yeah he's offered I mean he's great he's
offered he said hey I'll pay half your
rent because I'm actually not gonna live
with him I've decided I want to live on
my own so I'm I'm moving to a place I've
never been and I'm gonna live on my own
we're not going to live together I just
want to make sure that I like Boston for
me I want to make sure that if I guess
that'll didn't find my own way I'm
impressed
I'm impressed I mean look at the steam
yeah independent that you know had a
good situation
sounds like financially like with your
brother but didn't believe in it
like you've got a lot of things going
for you like don't want to move in with
him because you want to make sure like
you like it for you like yeah a lot of
you got a lot of good [ __ ] going on
thank you thank you let me tweak it a
little bit like don't go back to
corporate you know you don't like that I
think you go I think you go into now
first of all you might like corporate
you might have just not liked that one
company I mean helping right right now
he probably thinks I'm crazy so I'm like
I'll try pharmaceutical sales I'll try
real estate he's like you're all over
the place I'm like I just want to find
something that I love and I want to do I
don't want to because I work remote when
I pick up my computer I'm almost
miserable it's like every single day
I don't anyone look at my computer you
know I want to do something that I'm
excited about and I love marketing
because I love talking to people face to
face like that gives me energy for the
last two years I've been behind the
computer doing project management and
I'm like I can't look you're unique
more people detail might be good like
listen yeah to me one couple favors 128
to tricky here people start getting
impatient around this time so don't
don't don't get confused you're super
young you you have like five more
at-bats to find it number to definitely
put yourself in a position to be around
people okay yeah I mean that that's what
I do struggle with especially being in
the south I mean I feel like I'm behind
in a lot of ways when I come back here
everybody's like you know which is great
they have their own everyone you're not
you're not about that life
no I mean which I think it's great don't
get me wrong I think to each of them
whatever makes you happy but I want to
find and that's another thing about
going back into corporate is I I know
there's they chose wait yes he chose
there's a Michele Gina in the comments i
was reading she said she'll see hit me
up they thank you so much dustin they're
you know chose sure she's on Michelle is
that you know your Facebook comment
you're at Michelle master I'm gonna
assume that's Twitter and Instagram I'm
sure you'll find her shells but like
there you go thank you
get yourself around people yes and and
don't do the normal 28 year old thing
and get worried okay and I think that's
what I'm doing and I mean I listen to
you every single day what I got hooked
you when you I heard you on a podcast or
something you said
entrepreneurship is lonely as [ __ ] and I
was like oh my god who is this guy
because it is I mean I moved out to LA
thinking that you know I would I would
have this whole different life and I got
there and it was just so lonely for the
first six months but I'm so thankful for
going through that because now I'm like
I can move anywhere there's strong
affection talk to a brick wall
well just do me one favor just don't get
a job with the Patriots because then
we're finished okay I'll tell my waiver
in that I think these pages
I'm a Saints fan probably alright thank
you so much area secure I try to cut it
short everybody I've got something I
need to address inside the bounce but I
wish everybody a great great day hope
you're well thank you so much for
watching I can't wait to be back
tomorrow we'll go at it love you guys
take care of the people that are gonna
win over the next five to seven years
are gonna be very comfortable and
controlled [ __ ] chaos you don't love
the process this is rules requires
sacrifice all your actions have to then
map - back back back back back back
nobody gives a [ __ ] about where you grew
up
the whole game is scaling the unscalable
it's [ __ ] hard work it's being
respectful it's being a good person to
that that's just a good idea it's there
the flipping is there this house right
here that's $400 today I stay my way
like real [ __ ] tight but you can't be
crippled everybody here judging
themselves you're looking at what's in
front of you right now
you're losing cuz you're laying in your
bed looking at somebody's [ __ ]
glamorous photoshopped picture of them
doing something cool and you're envious
and you're jealous and you're impatient
and it's crippling you're upside let me
just say it one more time if you're
confused what I just said I say put your
[ __ ] flag on the ground who the [ __ ]
you are whoever provides the most value
always you're entering the greatest five
year window of your life my only answer
today or any much like it's just like
try [ __ ] shut your business down and go
work for an apparel company potaters
nobody you've ever met got there without
the hard work so you better get your
speed up you better work harder you
better work smarter you can't Google
stuff you're not
be able to do anything that I'm telling
Gary TV my vehicle to check me out
hope you enjoy